Jay Glazer of Fox Sports UFC host and
information man extraordinary good
friend of the program how you doing Jake
Tim good just to let you know where I'm
watching the fight
where are you watching I will be
probably breaking into your house
because I think you'll be somewhere else
that's right um I already got your
security oh but even if I don't you know
I had a as Liam Neeson said a very
particular set of skills and not all be
I love your linens okay so probably be
just you know cozied up there I think
maybe with it prior to and you know just
hanging out and probably the master
suite you're fine with that that's Jay
that's a little bit creepy but look were
that close and and and you know back in
high school my nickname was thread-count
Jay so you know I'm except it was
3-thread dad okay Frank out of three
what is it what do you make of this pie
Jay what do you think of this MacGregor
Mayweather well first of all look
there's a couple layers here the first
thing I'll tell anybody when it comes to
combat sports anytime you get to put
your hands and another man you can never
be sure the outcome you never know right
but the other end of the spectrum is
it's two completely different sports
boxing the difference for the mixed
martial arts completely different the
range is different because the gloves
are different obviously the strikes it's
interesting because when you line up
your range for boxing which is very
close to someone that's different than a
range for kickboxing immortai and then
the range for MMA is even further out
than that because of takedowns so it's a
completely different sport what I like
to compare it to is you know we've
trained
Jarryd Hayne a couple of years ago from
it was the best rugby player down in
Australia New Zealand and he comes out
here to American play in the NFL he
shows up is like alright well cause this
is what I gonna play oh my gosh I don't
know you tell me you're out here to
Train he's like I don't know anything
about the sport what am I going to play
so I literally called straya and I go so
I got a guy who was like the best rugby
player in the world and you know these
teams want him to play in the NFL one
issue is worth what are we going to put
him at he's like
put him in running back you get you got
to know less than all the other stuff so
put him a running back so here's the
best rugby player in the world and here
one of them and he made the 49ers
practice squad barely first few weeks
and that was it so it's a similar thing
you're playing a completely different
sport and conversely if you take a
little challenging it's room over there
and in Australian rules football Julio
is gonna struggle it off a lot it's a
completely different sport but man
well Connor has behind his rib cage I
just I don't count that guy out for
anything
no I guess we've come up with the the
tagline for this fight McGregor
Mayweather you never know said
essentially what it is you never know
hey whenever you get to put your hands
on the other man in the violence board
you never know what could happen and
what Connor is great at you you talk
about it the how much he hypes you up
how much he hides a fight up but he is
an incredibly smart fighter he is so
smart so what he does is he gets you so
so so so hyped up he gets you so
incredibly hyped up for this fight and
what happens is as you're about to get
in the ring he continues to you know
kind of antagonize you and get you to
sink but he's coming right out after you
right but instead as the fight begins
when you go run across the ring and I'm
thinking he's going to come right across
the running you and you know you're
going to just go at it he'll all sudden
lays all the way back he gets very
relaxed and that's where he's a
phenomenal counter puncher he's so
incredibly calculated and everything he
does Jay Glazer Fox Sports joining me
here on the Rich Eisen show so you being
as expert at training as you are the
number of people that you have trained
how would you train Conor McGregor for
this fight Jay if I'm Conor man I make
this the dirtiest filthiest fight you
can I put the crown of my head under
Floyd's chin against the ropes the
entire time I don't let him counter
punch I dictate the pace to fight I
dictate the range of the fight
I definitely don't fight it in Floyd
fight I get him against the ring
those ropes as much as I cannot put my
my head under his chin I make it nasty i
rip to the body i ripped to the head i
move them around i keep them in there
it's kind of like old rocky i mean
that's that's what i'm going to do so
you know Andre Barco just who's in our
gym yesterday and fought Mayweather he
just had a fight like that against
somebody and you know that's the style
at least that we try and train here and
unbreakable which is Randy Couture style
we just you know Randy's helped us build
it build it from there but you know last
guy he fought same thing I just put his
if the crown of his head under Bertos
chin and just walked away and walked
away and walked away and eventually you
go oh my god get this dude off of me and
it's just a more violent style leaving
two guys who are they're great counter
punchers Conor's not gonna be able to
beat the greatest counter puncher who's
ever lived counter punching so he's got
to do something else and he's got to do
something you got to make Floyd
incredibly uncomfortable I think that's
the best way to do it well I wasn't it
just referring when I say it when I say
the the crown of your head so if you
take you got to use your whole bodies or
weapon you take that that top part of
your head and you stick it under
someone's chin the whole time just leave
it there and move around on this cheek
in this chin they start getting
frustrated they start thinking about
that instead of your punches and we are
talking about your punches use your
crying ahead don't get me wrong I'm not
talking about heads letting them know
completely different no I know you're
saying and I let's get in there I wasn't
just referring to the X's and O's I'm
referring to the fact that only two of
his fights have ever gone longer than
two rounds and only ten of his fights if
you put it on an actual clock have
lasted longer than one round of boxing I
mean so how how will that work for
McGregor who looks pit clearly but has
never fought a fight where you've got to
go for one round three minutes and then
keep it going for as long as you can
well that's the other thing um you know
the cardio for boxing and MMA is
different because everybody it's a
violent sprint
well boxing is more of a marathon and
boxing is about getting in your rhythm
boxing is about you know making sure
that rhythm continues to to peak as you
know the fight goes on and you try to
catch someone with a good shot but you
know with MMA
you know I'll have our guys in here do
five minute rounds but every 20 seconds
they do something else because that's
how it is
you're never sitting there really and
you know a minute straight doing one
thing and try to get in this rhythm it's
a different kind of rhythm it's a I
guess said I kind of like it into a
violent sprint versus a marathon so it's
a different cardio where you constantly
have to you know your heart rate goes
and all sorts of crazy ways in that cage
in the ring you got to make sure you
relax you can go for that the full 12
rounds Jay Glazer joining me here for a
couple of more minutes a day after the
fight that we've been hearing whispers
about actually became reality Mayweather
McGregor joining me here Jay Glazer on
the Rich Eisen show so win or lose how
does McGregor go back to UFC I know that
that that everyone's talking about the
date of this fight is works on so many
levels including the fact that there's a
December 30th pay-per-view that McGregor
says he wants to fight in win or lose
how does he go back to a world where the
payday isn't even close to something
like this Jay and how does that affect
other fighters in the UFC who want to
get theirs oh no because I don't have a
hundred million bucks I can add to the
question for you an awful lot can change
here's the one thing I'll tell you
fighters it's in actually the guy who
beat Conor Nate Diaz said it best sport
institutionalizes you there's a reason
why guys continue do it over and over
and over and they're the certain guys
that go okay I'm taking my money I'm
gone like look George Sam Pierre he's
coming back you know I'll give that
Couture fought forever BJ Penn keeps
doing it boys Gracie did it years and
years later there's something about it
where it it just makes you feel
different than the rest of the world I
think it's a beautiful thing I think it
you know every when you walk in to get
you to say hey I'm not like everybody
else in here it's just there's something
there is this art to it so it's kind of
up to Conor Conor is like hey I got my
money we're gonna do my family I'm going
to go into acting maybe he does it but
there are certain guys where you know
he's the type of guy where you could
line up I can line up ten of the baddest
sob right now in Conor's probably gotta
fight them all right now I'm
certain people like that they like to
fight and it's not so much the wins and
losses it's it's the fight itself that's
a difference between these two guys the
biggest difference if Floyd is always
made sure I think Floyd thought
greatness is being undefeated greatness
is not being undefeated great is to
fight whoever the best is looking for
that guy who maybe could possibly beat
you and you beat him but if you beat you
and you come back and try and beat in
the next time that's what makes Muhammad
Ali's such a legend that's what makes
all those guys in the era of Hagler and
Hearns and letter and Guerette so
legendary
they all just fought each other looking
ok there baby I'm gonna try and beat him
again
that's what greatness is is you lose and
you come back and you try and beat that
guy who's supposedly superior to you
last one for you Jay put your NFL hat on
why is Kaepernick not have a gig right
now and do you see him getting one so
here's the thing there's not this a no
racial aspect here it's just this the
fact to the NFL and I should I told this
it to Michael Sam then I told it at
Tebow I told whoever it is teams judge
your circus verse your skill right so if
your circus is up high and your skills
over here then they tend to pull off man
can't move the circus right Odell
Beckham's the circus but their skill is
so much higher and the circus is you
know skill outweighs the circus that's
really what it is you know and let me
tell you something Colin Kaepernick to
me look I got all when Nate Boyer went
out and talked to Colin we have our MVP
foundation in here and we had a bunch of
we have 60 veterans in our gym we train
every Thursday including today and they
call back and ask what their thought was
and it was incredible how many vet said
hey do we agree with him not we agree
with him kneeling or simply look like
hell no but we fought for that right I
think that the biggest thing for Colin
is you know years ago when he was at his
best matthew is a monster
I remember Stan the NFC Championship
game stray and looking at him going this
is why don't play anymore look the size
of the dude and he had a 2/3
at you know aspect to his game he
doesn't anymore he lost a lot of weight
when he went through those surgeries
he's got to kind of get that tooth rep
back I think if he gets a tooth right
back and I haven't talked to sea oats
and wine in seinem I just think you know
there is a circus element that comes to
it good or bad right
it's still a circus element and half of
the guys later on their curricula this
dojo cinco's and the tos and you know
you know there's been a bunch of guys
where if your circus is higher than the
skill teams don't want to take a chance
and again I think the best thing to do
is get that weight back on to reach that
to threat no athlete again and then yeah
I mean shoot it brings that skill level
back up Jay thanks for the call brother
love chat with you event will chat soon
okay push everybody you gonna that's Jay
Glazer the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience if you like
that video be sure to download our app
and I'll be sure to help the NFL figure
out what it catches